Anna Carina de nouveau sur scène c'est
le résultat d'une histoire d'amour titre
de l'album qu'elle a fait avec Philippe
Catherine un jeune compositeur Anna
Carina légérie de Godard de
ginsbourg complicité pour la répétition
communion dans le travail respect mutuel
Anna Carina a tourné avec les plus
grands Rivette cucor et surtout Godard
qu'elle avait épousé en 1961 elle était
l'actrice fétiche de Philippe Catherine
qu'est-ce que je peux
faire je sais pas quoi faire moi je la
connaissais surtout dans les films bon
des des des années 60 et je trouvais
qu'elle avait pas changé et qu' c'est ce
qui m'a frappé en premier lieu et puis
que car il a beaucoup ça me plaisait
bien ça me fait
rigoler mais de la joie de vivre elle la
transporte aussi sur scène
ivard mais l mais entre toi moi ça me
fait rire tout
ça j'aurais pu être ta maman leur
rencontre date de l'an dernier elle a
tout de suite aimé le poète j'aurait pu
être ton
enfant
mais
je je l'admire je le trouve magnifique
je trouve que c'est le c'est le milieux
de sa génération et puis je pense que il
va bientôt
[Musique]
explosera toujours l'interprète de ce
classique de GB qu'elle chante désormais
avec une autre orchestration d'une voix
juste un peu plus
grave
rêvetique que je me
fais les yeux
verts et
pour c'est du RI sous le soleil
[Musique]
exactement
côé
sur le soil
exactement juste en
exactement
juste